This is kind of a random anecdote,...
...but I remember the first time I read an entire book in French.
I had to look up every other word.
It was a major struggle,..
...but I did it and it was a huge milestone for me.
Mainly at this stage of my life, I'm consuming self-help books,...
...or work on psychology and spirituality,...
...and it's almost entirely audiobooks.
But the point I'm trying to make here,...
...is there's no right way to do it.
What matters is that books are, in some way, a part of your life.
Learning new things has helped me with depression.
It's helped me with loneliness.
It's like it opens new doors when you think there's just no point.
It has never failed to give me...
...even just a little bit of purpose...
...in times when I have felt absolutely no sense of direction.
Also, you're looking at the work of many thousands of human beings.
Doesn't that restore your faith in humanity a little bit?
Look at what we're capable of.